>> Bryan: THE 80 MEETING BETWEEN
THE COYOTES AND HABS
TRYIN ET CETERA.
HE BROUGHT IT LAST NIGHT.
HERE COMES THE COCO GET THE PUC.
STRALMAN, DRIVES PLAY IN.
STRALMAN IS
GOING TO HANG IN THERE TO GO T
MISSED THAT.
ON THE SENATORS LAST NIGHT.
ANOTHER TWO-PO
COUPLE INJURIES FOR THE ONT.
PERREAULT SCORES!
PERREAULT HAS BROUGHT THEHE IN .
I DON'T KNOW IF PERREAULT
TOUCHES IT.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE TOU
GALCHENYUK, RIGHT IN FRONT.
SHOT.
GOAL! ON THE FIRST PASS FROM
MOSER OVER TO GALCHENYUK.
THAT'S THE ONE THAT COMES LAWSO
BREAKAWAY.
CROUSE, IN, SHOOTS, SCORES!!
GUY.
TAKES A LONG TIME TO S
HE'S LIKE I GOT PETRY AND
EDMUNDSON ON MY
WHO YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED TO
DISH FOR HOFFMAN.
HARD INTO THE BACKBOARDS!
BUT HE GOT UP PRETTY
>> Bryan: LAWSON CROUSE CREATING
HOFFMAN, PROTECTS THE PUCK.
SUZUKI IN TIGHT QWITH RTERS.
TO THE FAR BOARDS.OME PRESSURE.
AS EVANS GETS THE
RUN A COUPLE GOOD PLAYS.
NOW GOTTEN A GOOD ANGLE.
BECAUSE EDMUNDSON HAVING A H HSE
SENDS IT ACROSS.
GOOD SCREEN BY LEHKONEN BUT A
HE DID IT AGAIN!
TIME FROM MY STRONG SIDE.
LITTLE DRIV
MACCELLI DIGGING FORR NET AND H
IT.
BETWEEN CAULFIELD AND SUZUKI